[Musique]
Djibouti et géographiquement très bien
placé vous avez par exemple devant
Djibouti 70% du trafic conteneur qui
rejoint l'Europe et la France
[Musique]
en vertu du traité de coopération en
matière de défense entre la République
française et la République de Djibouti
la France participe à la police du ciel
et donc à la souveraineté de l'espace
aérien djiboutien à ce titre et bien il
est important d'être capable de
coordonner l'ensemble des activités dans
l'espace aérien et donc d'être capable
également par ailleurs de détecter toute
menace et ça c'est le rôle de notre
centre militaire de contrôle qui 24
heures sur 24 et 7 jours sur 7 veille à
identifier toutes toutes menace
potentielle et à déclencher la
permanence opérationnelle si besoin on
est
la chaleur qui fait que l'avion a déjà
réagi différemment et un peu moins de
puissance un peu moins de pousser et
aussi la gestion du stress thermique
avec une bonne hydratation une
acclimatation obligatoire etc pour
pouvoir supporter une chaleur un peu
plus importante sachant qu'on n'a pas la
climatisation quand l'avion est pas en
l'air donc on perd pas mal d'eau avant
de décoller
[Musique]